what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time well
while she's trying to get rich the rest
of us just trying to get our lunch money
right
you know what that means block five's
now the sponsor of lunch money i'm here
with lina she has a prisoner outfit on
no worries blackfy.com go there you can
earn up to 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can sign up for the waitlist for the
bitcoin rewards credit card
regular credit card you swipe it and
you'll get bitcoin back rather than
cashback
or airline miles go to blockfi.com
pomp what's up jamie dimon the ceo of
jpmorgan has listed the legal and
regulatory status
of cryptocurrencies among a list of
serious emerging
issues that need to be dealt with in a
letter to shareholders he describes his
view
on how aspects of the business are
bogged down in the past and need to
focus on the future
there are serious emerging issues that
need to be dealt with and rather quickly
he wrote
uh basically listing the legal and
regulatory status of cryptocurrencies
alongside the growth of shadow
banking cybersecurity risks and ethics
around
a.i uh
all i am going to say is that
jp morgan has been caught up
in more violations of regulation and law
than the crypto industry that's all i
have to say
so maybe it's the possibility
um next by the way i forgot to put it on
here but you want to talk about
uh coinbase real quick coinbase
730 to 800 million dollars in net income
in q1
rocket ship april 14th buckle up
your boy will be watching
so i love this company i was like one of
the first users somehow
canva uh it is a
it is a design unicorn at this point
less than a year after securing a six
billion dollar valuation of
a pandemic usage boost design unicorn
canva has more than doubled the
valuation for its design software tools
making two of its co-founders
billionaires in the process
uh it's based in australia and it just
raised 71 million dollars in new funding
led by t rowe price and dragoneer at a
15
billion dollar valuation melanie perkins
the ceo
is a sa vage the product works
great execution real serious business
from an economy
they get you in on the free plan and
then hit you
and you're like i am going to pay poland
should be a billionaire if she was one
of the first 50 users well i don't know
if i was one of the first 50 but i found
it really early on in 2014.
when was this started i don't know okay
oh launched in 2013. so i found it a
year after it was started
that is pretty early maybe you shouldn't
be a billionaire but you should be a
sent a millionaire
do you notice scent a millionaire is a
hundred millionaire
hundreds okay
club speaking of more funding clubhouse
is this the buzzy audio platform is
discussing
is in talks to raise funding from
investors and around valuing the
business at about 4
billion a pr a deal at that price would
quadruple its value from january and
would reflect the astronomical
expectations
investors have for this app didn't it
just
talk about raising money is it raising
money again what is happening
in january it announced a billion dollar
valuation no it's
four bill four billion is undervalued
wow
did they forex the user base since then
probably
they in a down month of march they
signed up two and a half million users
wild yeah bang bang whatever i love
having conversations
bang bang what up everybody get that
money ready
another funding plaid announced the 425
million funding round led by altimeter
capital with participation from new
investors silver lake and rivet capital
basically uh this financing boosts
plaid's valuation of 13.4 billion
and if you remember early last year visa
agreed to buy it for 5.3 billion
but then the deal fell apart so now it's
reached a higher valuation than
what it was going to get bought for
part of this in my opinion is
we are watching everything we're
watching everything
get repriced because the tech company
valuations were
undervalued we saw that once they would
get into the public markets it would
explode in value
so the private market is repricing this
stuff plaid at 13 billion
seems cheap really it seems like
everybody's raising money
no raising the money is fine it's what
the valuations are next evaluation is
also
i don't know all right guys supply chain
problems are reaching into a far corner
of the business universe
there is a catch-up shortage
are we serious right now are we serious
that you're gonna have phone calls going
off in the middle of my show
all right restaurants are trying to
secure the table top staple ketchup
after kovit appended the condiment world
order
managers are using generic versions
pouring out bulk ketchup into individual
cups
and hitting the isles of costco for
substitutes it's crazy somebody was like
yo we should take some of this ketchup
and put it in little baggies
that is wild like anybody ever thought
about that like who was the genius who
was like
let's not sell it in the big can let's
put it in little bags this is not the
point
it'd be like me putting water in a
little bag and selling it
they do that actually the point is that
is not the point the point is there was
there was a ketchup shortage guys
well you know maybe they need a better
supply chain
maybe they need a better supply chain
maybe but cups of ketchup are filled for
takeout orders at
jester concepts restaurant in
minneapolis
i'm not gonna make judgment on jester
concepts but i don't know if i was
driving down the road if i would stop at
jesters
because you're a jester
okay um it's ask lunch money time
hashtag ask
elem in the comments moist continues his
journey
day 92 of commenting i've got my email
notifications turned on and i'm waiting
eagerly
the grind has continued nonetheless i
too recently found out about this face
exclusive soap
my mom put me onto and has really helped
with acne now i have four bottles in my
shower shampoo conditioner soap and face
soap yo moist let me tell you about the
two in one you get the
shampoo and the conditioner in one way
more efficient in the shower are you
going to email
do i have his email yes oh all right i
gotta get it
i'm message bankrupt if you message me
on any platform i'm
bankrupt i literally can't keep up with
it what about voice
i'm gonna email him yeah but you but
you're gonna you're gonna make sure that
you give me the
email matt but go has a question pomp if
you could create a financial institution
or its replacement what would your
vision look like bitcoin
wow period open network wins
bitcoin is the bank of the future just a
matter of time
foregone conclusion in my opinion all
right
is that it that's it you still got a
prisoner outfit on you look crazy
no worries love all of you i'll see you
guys later
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange i personally
use the interest bearing account
there's not very many places where
you'll find up to 8.6
interest on a deposit in an interest
bearing account go do your own research
there's risk associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfy
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends